joining us now with reaction daily
mail.com editor-at-large piers morgan
who by the way he's become a friend of
mine and he is once a competitor but you
know i know i never dislike them then
except about the second amendment we
will debate that one day you know I've
come to really admire your your fight
your wit your humor your your very
impressive and I read your stuff all the
time
you know liberals screaming to impeach
Trump you had a really you're on fire
well first of all Shawn thank you for
having me and can I just offer my
deepest sympathy to just as small a it
must be all terrible it must be awful
must mean to have post-traumatic stress
disorder
yeah from something that you faked
yourself I mean poor guy I think our
hearts go out to him right I mean all
those nightmares about did I or did I
not give them the right amount of money
and the check I pay these guys to stage
the fake race hate homophobic attack I
mean do me a favor so that got me angry
before we even started Shawn but let's
turn to this issue of the Miller report
because there are 400 pages of stuff in
there but what was the report set up to
be the report was set up very clearly to
investigate Lula was appointed to
investigate whether there was a
conspiracy by Donald Trump or his
campaign team with the Russians to
basically fix the election I can't
imagine a more serious charge against
any serving president than they betrayed
their country with a foreign enemy to
fix a US election and for two years the
media in this country and the Democrats
and screaming liberal celebrities like
Josie Smollett who led the charge on
this for those celebrities have screamed
collusion collusion collusion collusion
right this was a done deal Muller was
the savior he was the man on the white
horse riding into town to take down
President Trump on collusion with Russia
he would be exposed as a traitor and
this would be the end of his presidency
and then the mullah report comes out and
it turns out it was all nonsense it was
to quote Donald Trump it was fake news
so I turned
Shawn the day after the full report was
published I looked at the papers that
the Washington Post and The New York
Times who both won Pulitzer Prizes for
their coverage a Russia collusion and
neither of them remembered to mention in
their banner headlines the day after the
full publication of the full report
neither of them remembered to mention
that the conclusion by mullah
was there was no collusion instead they
went for more Trump bashing I turned to
cable news some of your rivals some I
used to work at and they too moved very
swiftly from collusion that they've been
screaming about for two years to now
obstruction of justice so let's analyze
that for a couple of seconds we're
supposed to believe now that Donald
Trump committed repeated obstruction of
justice over a crime that he now as we
all know did not commit so he's trying
to obstruct people from investigating
something he said he didn't do that the
special counsel has now confirmed he
didn't do it is ridiculous it is a fast
it's making a mockery I think of America
in the same way that back in my country
over brexit our departure from the
European Union the people who lost who
voted remain I was one of them refused
to accept the result do not want the
country to Braga's it the Liberals here
you saw refusing to accept the results
of the Trump win in 2016 but Hillary won
the the popular vote who cares about a
popular vote and now they refused to
accept the results of the Miller report
the one that they said would be
absolutely the fire Salus the sacrosanct
say it is a disgrace that was so well
done I I can't top that
I really can't you're you're edgy your
news the Daily Mail is edgy this isn't
edgy this is outright lying and
conspiracy theories based on mostly on
anonymous sources what is the fallout I
don't think they ever get rid of the
fake news branding of Donald Trump I am
actually staggered the
CNM rise to work and I've lot of friends
there had great respect for the network
because but I do but unfortunately on
this they just have gone completely in
the tank anti-trump and I don't know why
they've done that other than that make
gives them you know a lot of money I
guess but I think it damages their
credibility I wish they weren't doing it
I wish that somewhere in America would
go back to just representing Trump in a
fair way that you could actually say
look the mother report came back and
said no collusion end period move on if
the Democrats fueled by the media now
try and continue to fight this I'm
telling you what will happen Shawn
Donald Trump will get reelected and
they're gonna have four more years of
this amazing analysis we hope you'll
come back more often great to see you
again
here's Morgan thank you